[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt in
meinem letzten kurzvideo habe ich
irgendwas shots zubereitet die wirklich
super einfach sein in der herstellung
ihr könnt sie vier bis fünf tage im
kühlschrank lagern und dann einfach
jeden tag einen kleinen ingolstadt
trinken
es stärkt das immunsystem und es
wirklich super vitaminreich heute gibt
es wieder ein video und zwar mache ich
heute goldene milch vielleicht habt ihr
schon davon gehört die goldene milch
wird auf basis von kurkuma hergestellt
kurkuma ist eine gelb wurzel die
wirklich total positiv sich auf den
körper auswirkt zum einen hat die
heilende eigenschaften in der
ayurvedischen medizin witze oft
eingesetzt sie stärkt das immunsystem
sie ist entzündungshemmend auch gerade
bei chronischen erkrankungen wie
gelenkschmerzen arthrose zum beispiel
sie senkt den blutzuckerspiegel und noch
vieles weiteres was ich gleich noch
erzählen werde
wichtig ist zu wissen dass ihr gemahl in
kuba nehmen könnt aber da müsst ihr
einfach beim kauf darauf achten denn da
gibt es wirklich kurkuma im supermarkt
was total blei belastet ist also viel
mit schwermetall weil es einfach in
bangladesch angebaut wird und dort das
ganze sozusagen mit schwermetallen
versetzt wird damit die farbe gold gelb
ist achtet da wirklich drauf das
wirklich super wichtig denn ansonsten
kommt es zu einem erhöhten bleibt laut
spiegel und das ist wirklich gar nicht
gut
also für das rezept brauche ich nur ganz
wenige zutaten ihr könnt es vegan zu
bereiten oder auch ganz traditionell mit
milch und honig ich zeige euch einfach
weitere alternativen
ich stelle jetzt erst mal eine cola
passte her denn die könnt ihr einmal zu
bereiten im kühlschrank lagern und dann
habe ich sie einfach immer griffbereit
und könnt euch jeden morgen oder jeden
abend einfach eine kuh milch machen die
gold level zu machen und habe dann echt
gar nicht mehr viel arbeit damit für die
paste nehme ich jetzt hier vier
esslöffel kurkuma einen teelöffel
pfeffer etwas wasser und dann brauche
ich noch für die goldene mint für eine
portion ich rechne das jetzt mal auf ein
glas bereit natürlich wieder mehr zu
fürs team
aber ich zeige es euch hier für ein glas
habe ich hier 200 milliliter milch ich
habe 10 h milch ihr könnt man sich unter
normale milch nehmen und dann habe ich
hier noch etwas honig und eine prise
zimt und benutzt gleich natürlich ein
bisschen was von meiner
kurkuma passte also wie gesagt bereite
ich jetzt hier die paste form ihr müsst
ihr passte nicht machen ihr könnt doch
einfach jeden tag und ich alle zutaten
zusammenmischen natürlich dann nicht so
viel kummer sondern etwa nur ein
teelöffel oder bis esslöffel pro 200
milliliter ich mache das jetzt einfach
so da die passte also das cocoa pulver
sich im wasser nicht so gut auflöst und
dann verrückt es jetzt erst einmal habe
die paste bereit und dann ist es
wirklich super einfach mit der milch mit
der herstellung pfeffer muss auf jeden
fall mit dazu weil da präparieren
enthalten ist und heparin sorgt dafür
dass unser körper coco besser aufnimmt
außerdem solltet ihr wirklich auch euren
eltern und großeltern eigentlich schon
jeden tag die goldene milch machen denn
kurkuma weckt auch wirklich ganz toll
gegen alzheimer und entgiftet sogar die
leber es hat wirklich super
eigenschaften also ich hab das pulver
jetzt hier drin
hier kommt jetzt das wasser dazu sind
wir einfach so ein kleines köpfchen aus
dem ich später auch gut aus gießen kann
jetzt wird es hier verrührt und kurz
erwärmt und so entsteht jetzt die passte
also schloss ist jetzt gar nicht kochen
sondern wirklich nur kurz erwärmen
[Musik]
das habe ich hier diese passte das hat
etwa vier bis fünf minuten gedauert die
dicke nämlich so ein bisschen ein
ich fühle die mir jetzt um
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich hier von einem
esslöffel und mach jetzt einmal diese
milch also ich habe jetzt hier h milch
ich verwende jetzt hier honig und zimt
und beim honig achte ich einfach drauf
dass ich regionalen imkerhonig habe ihr
könnt aber auch zum beispiel datteln
sirup nehmen oder agaven dicksaft
einfach so eine leichte süße reinbringen
zimt wird ja auch super von innen
deswegen noch eine prise zimt aber mach
mich zu viel sind rein ansonsten wird es
getränke nämlich eher braun und ich
finde das getränk echt schön weil es
gerade so gold ist da hat auch seinen
namen als auch immer noch ganz kurz
erwärmen und dann können wir schon
probieren
[Musik]
ja das ist gold eine milch wollt ihr mal
probieren ja das ist einfach warme milch
mit honig gold eingefärbt
und der andere geschmack das ist kurkuma
und das was voll lecker gern das hält
uns fit und gesund oder makler bisserl
vanille extrakt
für die kinder gibt es auch wandel
extrakt dann ist es die sally mehlis kam
dennoch ein bisschen ganz wenig ja weil
ihr habt ihr nur eine kleine menge ganz
wenige stoppt also ich find sie mega
lecker frühjahr haben dass die menschen
getrunken damit sie ganz lange jungen
sind das nämlich antioxidantien drin
und dass man keine falten kriegt und
dass man immer noch schöner wird
er lag gleichwohl start ob ich sehe das
schon deine haut wird immer jünger
wow max öfter warme milch trinken
goldene mint okay aber ich mache die
goldene mitte
dann macht einfach die augen zu haben
sich die fahrer wenn ich nein
ich mache doch eine große portion fürs
team kommt jeder wieder auf seine
strichliste irgendwo schutz werden auch
getrunken und das rezept gibt es
natürlich auf meiner auf meinem blog und
in meiner app da könnte es gerne
nachlesen und auch gerne ein foto posten
mit dem hashtag felix welt dann sehe ich
nämlich
[Musik]
okay kommt die milch ist fertig bevor
ihr jungs gegen mädchen die jungs gegen
mädchen medien gegen jungs jungs sind
wie waffen keine farbe bekennen
geschmack den witz ohne lacht ich denke
ich darüber nach wenn ich den text
dieser ausdruck einer weißen jungs gegen
mädchen kann man ganz hinter der kamera
konya schlug vor man kann ja mehr honig
rein machen oder so gut oder märz nimmt
[Gelächter]
für mich könnte auch mehr kummer sein
okay okay wir arbeiten weiter
[Musik]